R
JOB AND THEIR COMMITMENT.
THANK YOU, RODNEY.
>> THE PRESIDENT SAID HE NEVER
SPOKE TO HIS SON ABOUT HIS
BUSINESS DEALING?
HAS HE EVER SPOKEN ABOUT HIS
SON'S, BUSINESS DEALINGS?
>> NOTHING HAS CHANGED.
THE PRESIDENT DOES NOT GET
INVOLVED IN THE BUSINESS
DEALINGS OF HIS SON?
>> Reporter: EVEN THROUGH HIS
SON'S BUSINESS PARTNERS?
>> Secretary Psaki: NOTHING HAS
A CHANGE.
>> Laura: TO ANNOUNCE FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE HAVE BECOME A LITTLE
BIT UNBELIEVABLE, NOW BRENDA
REPORTING'S FROM THE DAILY MAIL
RECEIVED -- JOE BIDEN AGREED TO
PAY HIS SON HUNTER POPPER'S
LEGAL FEES FOR THIS DEAL WITH
THIS CHINESE
GOVERNMENT-CONTROLLED COMPANY.
HE WAS ONLY ABLE TO PAY THE
BILLS AFTER HE EARNED MOUNDS OF
DOLLARS THROUGH HIS AND HIS
WIFE'S COMPANIES.
AND HERE NOW IS FORMER SPEAKER
OF THE HOUSE FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR NEWT GINGRICH.
THE LEFT WAS SO OBSESSED, IT
REMAINS OBSESSED WITH TRUMP'S
FINANCES.
THESE SEEM TO BE GROWING EVER
MORE GLARING AND OBVIOUS ON THE
PART OF BIDEN EVERY DAY AND YET
PSAKI IS LIKE NOTHING TO SEE
HERE.
THEIR REACTION?
>> Speaker Gingrich: NOBODY ON
THE LEFT IS GOING TO ADMIT THAT
YOU NOW HAVE A CORRUPT FAMILY
WITH A LINE PRESIDENT.
OR EVEN THOUGH IT IS PATENTLY
OBVIOUS.
BUT JOE BIDEN DID NOT PUT A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS INTO
PAINT HIS SON'S LEGAL BILLS WITH
NO KNOWLEDGE.
THERE WERE NOT 27 DIFFERENT
OCCASIONS RECRUIT BUSINESS
ASSOCIATES OF HUNTER BIDEN WERE
IN THE OBAMA WHITE HOUSE AND
AGAIN, THIS IS NOT JUST JOE
BIDEN.
IT IS ALSO BARACK OBAMA.
AND IT IS HARD TO BELIEVE THAT
THERE WERE 27 DIFFERENT VISITS
AND OBAMA DID NOT NOTICE THAT IT
WAS ON THAT SCHEDULE.
THE SAME TIME, I THINK THAT MUCH
BIGGER STORY, THOUGH, PRESENTLY
IS THAT MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS THAT THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST GAVE TO THE UNIVERSITY
OF PENNSYLVANIA WHILE JOE BIDEN
HAD ESTABLISHED A LITTLE SCHOOL
THERE.
ALL THAT HAS BEEN SECRET.
THE UNIVERSITY OF PENNSYLVANIA
REFUSES TO ADMIT HOW MUCH MONEY
THEY HAVE TAKEN FROM THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST PARTY.
BIDEN REFUSES TO ADMIT HOW MUCH
CONTROL HE HAD OVER THAT MONEY
AND YOU TAKE THAT KIND OF
CORRUPTION AND THEN YOU ADD TO
WHAT WAS HAPPENING WITH HUNTER
BIDEN.
WHO APPARENTLY WAS GETTING MONEY
FROM CHINA, FROM UKRAINE, FROM
RUSSIA, AND IT IS AMAZING TO
LOOK AT THE FRONT PRINTS AROUND
THE WORLD AS THE BIDEN FAMILY
BUSINESS AND THAT IS REALLY WHAT
IT WAS.
THE BIDEN FAMILY BUSINESS.
NOT JUST ABOUT HUNTER BIDEN.
BUT IT IS ABOUT THE CURRENT
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
WHO I THINK CLEARLY HAS LIED TO
THE COUNTRY OVER AND OVER AND
OVER ABOUT THIS ISSUE.
>> Laura: I MEAN, NEWT, ANYONE
WHO IS A PARENT KNOWS THAT, I
MEAN, YOU REACH A CERTAIN AGE
BUT THE ONLY THING YOU CARE
ABOUT REALLY IS THAT YOUR KIDS
ARE DOING OKAY.
AND THAT OF COURSE YOU ARE
INVOLVED.
YOU ARE NOT RUNNING THEIR
BUSINESS BUT YOU KNOW WHAT YOUR
KIDS ARE DOING.
OR OTHERWISE YOU ARE NOT JUST
NOT A VERY GOOD PARENT.
SORRY.
AT THIS IDEA THAT -- OH, I DID
NOT KNOW.
I NEVER TALKED.
IT IS JUST PRESENTLY ABSURD.
>> Speaker Gingrich: JUST TAKE
THE FLIGHTS ON AIR FORCE TWO
MERKEL HUNDRED WAS WITH HIS DAD
GOING TO CHINA.
THEY WANT TO TELL US THAT ON A
14 OR 16 HOUR FLIGHT, NEVER IT
SAID, G, HUNTER, WHAT ARE YOU
DOING OVER HERE?
HOW IS THE BUSINESS GOING?
AND THAT REFERENCED THAT HUNTER
HIMSELF MADE WHICH CAME UP
AGAINST TO THE LAPTOP, THAT HE
WAS LITERALLY HAVE HIS MONEY WAS
GOING TO SUBSIDIZE HIS FATHER.
RIGHT NOW, THIS IS DURING A
PERIOD WENT JOE BIDEN WAS THE
VICE PRESIDENT.
THIS WAS NOT WHEN HE LEFT
OFFICE.
IT IS AMAZING TO ME THAT YOU
COULD HAVE THIS BLATANT LEVEL OF
CLEARLY TAKING FOREIGN MONEY AND
AT -- IN AN ILLEGAL WAY BY THE
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES AND HIS FAMILY WHO ARE
RUNNING A FAMILY BUSINESS.
THAT IS WHAT IS REALLY INVOLVED
HERE, INCLUDES JOE'S BROTHER.
THAT INCLUDES HIS SON AND IT IS
CLEARLY THE EXPLICATION OF HIS
PUBLIC OFFICE IN ORDER TO ENRICH
THE FAMILY.
>> Laura: WITH ART THE CLINTON
FAMILY FOUNDATION, THE GLOBAL
INITIATIVE, WE THOUGHT THAT WAS
KIND OF LIKE, BIG CASH COW, YOU
KNOW, REVOLVING DOOR OF
INFLUENCE, PEDDLING.
I MEAN, THIS IS -- WHICH ONE DO
YOU THINK IS WORSE, NEWT?
THE CLINTONS AND CORRUPTION OR
THE BIDENS?
>> Speaker Gingrich: I THINK IT
HAS BEEN AN EVOLVING PROCESS.
BEFORE I THINK THAT THE BIDEN'S
SAW WHAT HILLARY AND BILL, GET
AWAY WITH AND THOUGHT, WHY NOT
AS?
AND I THINK THAT WE ARE IN
DANGER OF FOREIGN GOVERNMENT
BEGINNING TO REALIZE THAT
CORRUPTING AMERICAN OFFICIALS
MAY BE THE MOST EFFECTIVE
FOREIGN POLICY YOU CAN HAVE.
SO YOU HAVE, YOU KNOW, THE WIDOW
OF THE MAYOR OF MOSCOW HAPPENS
TO SEND THREE AND A HALF MILLION
DOLLARS TO HUNTER BIDEN, JUST
HAPPENS TO DO IT.
I'M SURE HUNTER DID NOT TELL HIS
DAD.
YOU KNOW?
HE HAD TWO AND A HALF-MILLION.
>> Laura: NO.
>> Speaker Gingrich: THIS IS
CRAZY.
THEY THINK WE ARE SO STUPID AND
THEY ARE SO CONFIDENT THAT THEY
WILL BE PROTECTED BY THE ELITE
MEDIA AND IT WILL BE PROTECTED
BY THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.